okay so we're super excited to have
James today he's going to be talking to
us about first of all he's a student at
Berkeley with San John and he's gonna be
talking to us about a post quantum
multi-party computation so excited to
take away James okay Thanks so yeah I'll
be discussing this this upcoming work on
post quantum MPC this is join with Amit
pitbull dr. shaitan Giulio and so yeah
sorry it's not online yet before the
talk but it will be in a few days so
okay so yeah so first I'll go through an
outline so of this talk so I'll start
with an introduction like motivate the
question and discuss some like
challenges that are specific to the post
quantum setting and then I'll basically
have like three technical sections so
the first I'll discuss a parallel
no-cloning simulation technique that we
develop and this work and this is built
off a recent technique that has been
introduced in these three works and I'll
be like you know reviewing this this
technique and then showing how we extend
it to the multi-party setting and you
know a technical tool we use to do that
is is quantum multi key fhe which we
construct and so in this section I'll
discuss like mahadev a single key
quantum fhe and then how we build on
that to get multi key variants and
finally the other another technical tool
we need our post quantum not malleable
commitments and so I'll discuss these in
the final section okay so so first yeah
so what is a secure NPC you know we have
a set of a set of parties they each have
their their private input and their goal
is to compute some public function some
some circuit over all of their private
inputs and they'll do this by
communicating with each other and for
security we want to say that if we have
an adverse a
that is corrupting and controlling some
set of parties we want to say that this
adversary doesn't learn like anything
about the honest party inputs through
interacting in this in this protocol
except for what what it should learn
from just the result of the circuit okay
and this is you know really a general
widely studied notion in cryptography
with many flavors of security
definitions and most of these flavors
are you know based on what type of
adversary we're considering and so one
like very common setting is to say let's
consider a computationally bounded
adversary so we'll restrict them them to
run in polynomial time but we'll allow
them some any some arbitrary number of
corruptions so they can corrupt say up
to like n minus 1 parties as long as
they they choose who to corrupt before
the protocol begins and then proceed
from there and you will let them like
act you know once the protocol starts
will let them act in an arbitrary
malicious fashion meaning they can
instruct the the parties they corrupt is
to compete their their messages in an
arbitrary way based on any polynomial
time strategy so this is a very familiar
setting and indeed like this is an
incomplete list of citations of like you
know works that have studied exactly the
setting of NPC you know with a
computation about it adversary
computationally bounded malicious
adversary so so everything I would
discuss so far I've been in the
classical world I guess these all these
machines or classical machines they of
classical inputs and they want to
compute a classical function so we're
gonna stick with des that but we want to
say we want to ask what happens when we
you know give adversary more power so
namely we we we let the adversary
actually be a quantum polynomial time
machine and you know studying in
cryptography in the last couple decades
studying classical primitives secure
against quantum adversaries is
in a huge research direction especially
an encryption digital signatures and so
on you know but in this in the MPC
setting it turns out once we once we go
to this setting not much is actually
known so there's these works in the
two-party setting that give basically a
way to do general two-party computation
secure against quantum adversaries and a
polynomial number of rounds and as far
as we're aware in the multi-party
setting there's you know there hasn't
been any works that have explicitly
studied this so this is you know this is
where our main result comes in so you
know what we show in this work is there
exists a classical MPC protocol that is
actually just constant rounds in the
plain model so this was implicit in the
in the slide and the last slide I wasn't
assuming any sort of trusted setup so we
have this classical MPC protocol on the
plane model secure against quantum
polynomial time adversaries and so we're
going to need to assume so the mildly
superpolynomial hardness of learning
with errors along with the polynomial
hardness of some circular security
assumption so I'll say a little bit more
about these assumptions before moving on
so that the first what do I mean by mild
to mild superpolynomial hardness it's
just that you know no no quantum
polynomial time adversary has advantage
better than 1 over lambda to the
iterated log of lambda and breaking lwe
so this is you know very barely
superpolynomial particular this is like
weaker than assuming say the
quasi-polynomial hardness of lwe and
this is this assumption we need in
particular to build our post quantum
non-viable commitments so the other the
circular security assumption is is is
what we use it to do is to build quantum
multi key fhe and in fact a special key
week we end up needing a special case of
multi tfhe which i will explain later
but it's it's going to be spooky
encryption
which is a classical notion but we you
know port it to the quantum setting and
it's just basically it turns out to be a
special case of multi key fhe and and
what we use this to build is a first of
all a constant around parallel
extractable commitment and the novelty
here is in the parallel setting and just
so you have like a picture in your head
a parallel track movement commitment is
a setting where you have a single
receiver interacting with multiple
committers at once and you want to say
if there's you know an adversary that
occur UPS all these committers at once
then even in such a case there exists an
extractor that can they can extract all
of their inputs and so even though even
if these like committers are operating
in parallel so we also use this multi
key of this quantum multi KF h e to
build parallel parallel zero knowledge
it's a similar setting where we have
multiple verifiers interacting with one
prover if you know if they're all
corrupted at the same time they're still
going to be a simulator that simulates
their view okay so this is so these
tools is parallel zero knowledge this
parallel extractable equipment these non
valuable commitments they all we combine
all of these two to end up with our
concert on a PC protocol so James
there's always like this subtle to you
and when we deal with post quantum stuff
which is like whose quantum and who's
not and like I spent particularly for an
interactive primitives right so like I
guess even an MPC there's like a
question of like I'm some classical like
honest party and the adversary run me in
superposition right I guess the answer
is usually no to that yeah but now I'm
very confused about quantum multi kiev a
cheat because that sounds like there are
quantum circuits involved so like we
really are gonna like the good guys are
gonna run a constant figure as well so
they okay so well we'll get to this but
honest parties are going to be
completely classical and the you know
running like the quantum circuit only
comes up in the security proof you know
when we want to
we wanted to simulate the adversary's
view right a dresser it's gonna be a
quantum machine so I see sounds very
cool
[Music]
so so this security has nothing to do
with sort of leveled versus fully
homomorphic induction your do using it
for completely different purposes that
right leveled versus I mean see security
sort of gets you from level homomorphic
encryption to directly fully yeah I mean
that's essentially what we're using it
to do in this setting as well oh that is
okay okay I see interesting and I guess
the second question is do you this is
the is the MPC protocol you get it's
constant around but is it also succinct
is it also sustained because you know
that it actually depends on you know I
guess maybe what so as you'll see we're
going to use a basically a post quantum
mbc protocol in the crs model uh-huh
which already exists so that's the
synced then I believe that our protocol
should be succinct hi so your building
block is a post quantum ABC in this
Cirrus model with many rungs presumably
right yeah okay all right thanks yeah so
one more question is there do you make
black box use of the adversary or make
not black box use of adversity non box
yeah so yeah was I mean this was to go
see all of this shortly so yeah so as I
just said basically this this approaches
to take you know you know these post
quantum NPC protocols with trusted set
up exist in the literature and these are
some examples of them as long as you
instantiate them with appropriate like
post quantum primitives so yeah for
example like this the smoother J works
for example is going to be succinct yeah
so so you know even better so that yeah
they they have trusted set up but
the trust is set up is is nice in the
sense that it's just a common random
stream so it's as unstructured as
possible and how the security proofs in
these these protocols work is the
simulator first programs of CRS with
some trapdoor and then and then it
simulates a completely straight line
from there and so this this works well
with with quantum adversaries so you
know for us it suffices to basically
have the parties first agree on a common
random string a CRS and then run on B
and then run one of these protocols with
respect to that CRS and so this
basically amounts just showing how to
build a coin-flipping protocol in
constant rounds and so I'll get to
exactly what I mean by fully simulated
ball and you'll see why this this
interface isn't it nicely with the
simulated strategy of programming CRS so
so what does coin-flipping it is
straight line a technical term or do you
just mean like at eye level it's okay I
guess it is
I guess it's become a technical term it
just means that basically the simulator
is is not rewinding that we're sorry it
just kind of yeah okay thank you so yeah
and in fact maybe I should mention not
only is it is the simulator straight
line it's also it's also black box and
those those protocols as well okay so
this what is this coin-flipping
functionality it's it's it's a special
case of MPC but this is input list so
like each of these parties just have no
input and what they want to do is
communicate with each other and at the
end of the communication they want to
you they want the transcript of their
communication to fix some some string R
and ideally this R is going to be some
unbiased random string that they can
then use as a CRS so you know what's a
what's a natural way to try to achieve
this well you could have every party
like pick their own random string
broadcast it and then set like the the
sum of all these strings to be R
so this doesn't work right away because
they you know a malicious party could
wait to see the honest parties random
strings and then choose its own string
based on what it sees in order to bias
the outcome so to fix this a natural
approach is to first you know have every
party draw their string but then first
commit to it and broadcast that
commitment and only after everyone's
committed to their string then everyone
reveals what string they committed to
you and of course then they have to
prove that you know what they committed
to actually matched what they
broadcasted and will actually want these
parties to do this in zero knowledge
rather than just having them do it an
opening because eventually will be will
have to simulate the honest parties
doing this so this this this is why we
need zero knowledge here and then
finally if I call the proofs verified
then the common output will just be
being the sum of all these strings okay
so this is this is like the template to
follow at least so now like I'll say
like what are we okay what do we
actually want or what do I mean by fully
simulated well what security definition
are we going for here we have the an
adversary corrupting some some subset of
parties so this adversary is gonna
control these parties interact with the
honest parties and in this like real
world interaction this is going to
generate some distribution over the
adversaries final state at the end of
this interaction as well as the the
string that was fixed by the transcript
so we want to say that for any such
adversary there exists a simulator where
the simulator actually gets as input up
here some some external random string R
star okay so it gets us in put some some
string that's drawn at random and then
after that it's it simulates this
interaction with the adversary to
produce some final adversarial state and
a final transcript and I want to say
that the simulator is restricted to
outputting a transcript which fixes the
string R star that it received as input
I really want to say that these two
distributions are indistinguishable so
in other words like
the simulator is as program as forcing
the outcome of this transcript to be our
star and we want this to be even though
it's forcing this we want this to be
indistinguishable from the real world
interaction so now you know maybe you
can see like why this is useful like if
this R star is actually some some
programs ers for one of these for one of
these CRS model protocols then the
simulator can still simulate this
interaction and an instinct for way so
I'll discuss basically why this is you
know some challenges that come up in the
post quantum setting you know recall our
general template we have every party
commit and then broadcast and then and
then prove consistency so like I said
what we want to somehow have a simulator
force an outcome R star so a natural way
for the simulator to do that is to first
interact with the adversary and somehow
extract from the adversaries you know
first first messages extract the extract
their their their inputs RI and if the
simulator can extract what they
committed to then the simulator can set
the be honest party inputs appropriately
in order to fix this outcome R star
right so this is what we're going to
going to one to do and of course you
know a simulator like of course honest
party shouldn't be able to extract from
the adversary's commitments because
these commitments should be hiding
but the simulator should so you know
what does the simulators advantage over
the hottest parties as in any simulation
paradigm setting there's you know the
the one advantage it has is it actually
knows the adversary state and in fact
can choose the adversary state like this
my state I mean like maybe the random
coins used by the adversary at the
beginning and then like any intermediate
computational state that comes up during
that direction so you know that so so
okay so now that the simulator has
access to the state what can it do with
it and so I'm still kind of discussing
just the classical setting here and
there's been some really successful
techniques that have been developed
based on based around like what can a
simulator actually do with in with an
adversary state and one like hugely
successful paradigm is to have the
simulator rewind the adversary and this
is something you can do if you have
become if you have the state you know
let's just take the computation back up
and redo it and as many times as you
want you know another thing you can do
if you don't want to rewind you can also
clone the adversary if you know it's
state and so for example Barack's
technique is doing this you know on the
one hand the simulator is running the
adversaries next message
now in the other hand it's using a copy
of that adversary's state to using as as
a witness to some succinct argument okay
so you know in the in this in this and
this work we're interested in quantum
adversaries right so this adversary is
going to be a description of a quantum
polynomial size circuit but its state is
going to be in general quantum state so
we're asking what can a simulator do
knowing a quantum state and it turns out
that these two you know rewinding and
cloning are problematic so if that you
know if an adversary measures its state
then in general this is not a reversible
operation so rewinding becomes difficult
as first pointed out by on vandegraaff
although I will mention that there are
there are works that show that you can
actually do rewinding in certain
settings with the careful argument okay
but it's certainly not as widely
applicable of a of a strategy as in the
classical case and then cloning the
adversaries seems seems to mean in
general cloning quantum states is
impossible so this doesn't seem like a
useful strategy so and this work will be
interested in simulation strategies that
do neither of these things okay and that
yeah that'll bring us to the first
technical section so so here I'll be is
discussing
a so a what's been called the
homomorphic trapdoor paradigm and this
is basically an extraction technique
that does not rewind it does not clone
and it's showed up in these these works
of baton ski karana finesse anon flip
akka and Betances Schmeling in the last
year and so basically you know I'll
describe how it works it basically
consists of it makes use of two tools
okay the first tool is fully homomorphic
encryption and in fact the intuition
that homomorphic lis evaluating an
adversaries code could be potentially
useful in extraction kind of goes all
the way back to the be the impossibility
of
rock at all and it was made more
explicit in this in the attacks keep
enough like simulation technique based
on anafi scalable functions but you know
what gives fhe homomorphic encryption
it's its ability to be used in a non
rewinding way is really it's it's used
in conjunction with compute and compare
office Gatien okay so here is a computer
it's an office cater what this is is an
office cater for programs of the
following form compute and compare
programs that are parameterize by three
things a function a lock value and a
message okay so on it put X it evaluates
F on X and if it if this equals the lock
value it puts em and otherwise it just
outputs nothing
so it computes and compares to the lock
value so these works give a way to off
you skate these functions where the
office station of a particular compute
and compared program is
indistinguishable from some simulated
program which you can think of as an all
reject program as long as the lock value
has sufficient entropy given the
description of the function so and they
show how to do this under the lwe
assumption
so given these tools I can describe
basically at this point I'll be able to
describe like the core of the technique
so I'll be setting this up as a
interaction between a committer and a
receiver but I just want to distress
that this is like what I'm presenting is
not a full commitment it doesn't you
know right away satisfy all the hiding
and binding properties we might want but
this is kind of what this interaction is
is at the core of like of the
commitments and zero knowledge that
these works build so okay so what the
commander is going to do is first sample
some fhe keys and it's also going to
sample a uniformly random trapdoor value
and a uniformly random block value okay
it's going to come it's going to compute
an encryption of the trapdoor and then
it's going to compute the following
office keishon so of this particular
compute and compare program so what is
this doing it's it's taking as input
string which isn't it's interpreting as
a ciphertext
it's decrypting that ciphertext with the
secret key and if it happens to if that
ciphertext happen to be an encryption of
the lock value then it will output both
the secret key and the message that the
committer is committing to otherwise it
will output nothing okay
so you know given these these three
things the committer the committer will
release this this message which is the
public key the encryption of the trap
door and the dha'fi skated compute and
compared program given this the receiver
will attempt to guess the value of the
trap door so it's going to send back
some guests for the the value of the
chapter one and the committer will take
us and put that guess it'll see okay
what's the receiver right did it gets
trapped or right if so it'll return the
lock value otherwise over return nothing
okay so this is some some subroutine in
in a in a commitment but we'll see
basically how this how this allows
extraction okay
is just a string at this point you know
it doesn't seem to have semantics right
yeah chapter is just gonna be a random
string from there yeah no no special
structure there so okay so first like
why is this possibly just to get some
intuition I mean why is this possibly a
hiding like why is not releasing the
message um to the receiver well first
note that okay given the if fhe is
secure then the receiver like won't be
able to guess the value of trapdoor just
given this encryption you know thus this
the response will just be bought so lock
will be hidden from its view and if lock
is is independent of the receivers view
then you can apply compute and compared
security office Gatien security to show
that this is useless to the receiver
okay
and thus the message m is hidden so now
I'll just I'll discuss extraction using
this but first I just want to let's
let's make the following simplifying
assumption and so let's say that this
adversarial committer is explainable and
what I mean by explainable is the
following so every message it outputs is
actually going to be in the support of
some honest committer algorithm which
means it's consistent with some with
some random coins I'm used by an honest
committer okay so it's this this notion
of explained ability is a little similar
to the notion of semi malicious if you
familiar with that but the difference is
that or one difference is that this
committers is not actually giving the
extractor the random coins it's used it
used it's just guaranteed that like the
the messages that outputs are consistent
with some random coins that maybe the
extractor doesn't know and in fact these
random coins could be maliciously
generated right in any way so I will say
that this is a this is a non-trivial
class of adversaries but also you know
once you as these these other works kind
of kind of followed a similar two-step
process is like once you show that you
can extract from such committers then
you can kind of use other techniques to
extend extraction from explainable
committers to to arbitrary committers
and I won't be discussing that on this
talk because the main ideas still come
in when you're just dealing with
explainable committers okay so how does
this extraction procedure work this is
you know so they so they extractor now
now assume we're assuming it knows the
state of committer right and I guess for
the rest of this part you can kind of it
you can kind of think of this committer
as being classical or quantum kind of
everything I say applies to both
settings it just depends whether you you
think of the state as a classical string
or a quantum state okay so so the
extractor now well will first run the
committer run these first three steps
until it outputs its message and updates
its state so at this point right
intuitively in order to extract the
message the extractor is going to need
to somehow make use of this computing
compare alpha station and in order to do
that it's going to somehow have to come
up with an encryption of the lock value
right and in order to do that like it
seems like it needs the trap door like
that's the only way it can extract the
lock out of the committer but the thing
is that you know it doesn't have the
trap door in the clear but it has
non-trivial information about the trap
door namely the fhg encryption of it so
what it's going to do is is run the
final part of the committer under the
hood of the fhe in other words it's
going to like take this block of code
that is going to be run by the committer
along with the the state of the
committer and evaluate this home or
focally over the encryption of the trap
door which it has and you know this
should output exactly an encryption of
the lock value right since this trap
door is is the right value along with an
encryption of the updated state okay so
once the extractor has an encryption of
the lock it can directly evaluate the
compute and compare program on this lock
to obtain the secret key and the message
can output the message and then finally
can use the secret key to decrypt the
the final States and also
I also output the final state so note
that this yeah this extraction procedure
was an attack was entirely straight line
it did no rewinding and it did did no
cloning so I do want to mention that
again like I'm saying like I was saying
before this is not a full commitment one
thing that needs to be fixed in
particulars is this you know this is the
step for this code actually has to be
run under a secure something called a
secure function evaluation or some like
a special case of two PC and the reason
is that we don't want the committer to
like to realize if it's if it's
interacting with the extractor or the
ominous party and there's a couple other
changes that need to be made which I
won't discuss but hopefully this gives
kind of the core idea of how this how
the straight-line extraction is working
sorry James where does the encryption of
the state come from so you know this
this piece of code you know it operates
like this this this final commitment or
sorry that this final function along and
it operates on the current state of the
commit or whatever it is and so that
outputs like whatever the final the
value of this function along with the
the value of the state you know you you
know the committer whatever it runs some
procedure it's also updating its
internal state as its doing that right
so this you know if you run this thing
under the hood of fhe what you'll get is
the output as well as the updated state
so I will note that now like I said you
gotta they think of a state as being
classical or quantum in the case that
the state is quantum what we will need
this fhe to support evaluation of
quantum circuits okay so okay sorry
this is kind of trippy for me so just to
be clear like the function that you're
running eval on is the next message
function of the potentially adversarial
committer ass
your message number three so the message
sent I see okay which like the comater
we're honest would have this form but
it's not necessarily honest we could
have some crazy form so this is you know
this is a paradigm like this this core
idea has has shown up in slightly
different different ways in these
different papers BKP to do this it was
actually purely in the classical setting
to get some new results in the classical
setting and then these works show the
usefulness of this this core extraction
procedure in the in the in the quantum
setting and they use these to build
various things extractor you know
extraction procedures zero knowledge so
you know indeed yeah so so these these
two works showed how to basically get
new results in constant constant round
post quantum geo knowledge and this
wasn't this improved upon these these
these older results at least in terms of
round complexity so but note that you
know I'm like why I'd to subscribe and
zero knowledge in general is just an
interaction between one prover and one
verifier okay and so we're asking you
know is this extraction technique
actually useful to the multi-party
setting and in particular to to
multi-party coin flipping so that the
the thing here is that like if you think
back to the template that I had earlier
what a simulator must do it like an
adversary could be corrupting some some
set of parties that are running these
commitments in parallel and so the
simulator must somehow extract from an
adversary that is corrupting multiple
committers so we're asking I mean our
challenge here is to basically extend
this this this technique onto the
parallel setting okay so you know to be
yeah more explicit let's let's just for
the rest of this part let's just
consider an adversary that corrupts
exactly two parties or exactly two
committers so what's going to happen is
when you run this adversary on an
initial state it will first run the
first part of these committers right and
basically output
two sets of messages one per committer
okay the first is going to be the public
key the encryption as well as the
competing compared obfuscation the other
is going to be exactly the same thing
but generated with independent
randomness right so at this point you
know the second part of each of these
commitments are going to be these
function the functions that turn the
trapdoor into the lock as we just saw
but the challenge here is that thus the
extractor only gets kind of like one
chance to run this final this final
piece of code and it's since an
adversary in general is just kind of
like one one machine you can't basically
like you can't like split these two
parts up
you can't like run once and rewind you
can't clone the adversary so this is
really just one function that has to be
run a single time and intuitively we're
going to be wanting to run that
homomorphic way over both an encryption
of the trapdoor one and an encryption of
the trapdoor - okay and these are
encrypted under different public keys
potentially independently generated
public keys so here's what we want to do
we're going to evaluate this code over
these two encryptions but you know so
how do we evaluate something over two
independently generated public keys it
turns out we have a we have a tool for
this which is called multi key ifhe so
here if you if you take an encryption
under two independently encryptions
under two independently generated public
keys you can take a circuit and evaluate
it over them and out comes the cert
outcomes the the response so C of M 1 M
2 encrypted under both public keys at
once so when you run this evaluation
procedure what you'll end up with is
indeed encryptions of lock 1 and log 2
under both public keys at once along
with an encryption of the end of the
updated state ok so you know does this
mean we're done like can we run the same
can read from the same final procedure
as we saw on this in the single
committer case so let's look at a little
more carefully so what does the
extractor have at this point it has
encryptions of lock 1 and lock 2 under
both public keys and then it has a
computer compare office keishon with one
of the secret keys hard-coded on a
convenient compare off you station of
the other secret key card coded so now
it's I mean note that it's it's not
immediate that you can basically
evaluate either these compete and
compare programs on either of these
encryptions because these ciphertexts
are just simply not in the right form
and you know
and even worse like this the ciphertext
like you kind of need both secret keys
to decrypt it so you know one thing you
could try to maybe do is have the have
the set of committers like tell them to
like somehow jointly sample a compute
and compared program that has both of
the secret keys hard-coded in it but
this appears to require some sort of
general purpose NPC which is what we are
trying to build in the first place so
will basically show how to how to make
do with just this information so and
basically so everything I'm just doing
this in the to the to commit or setting
but everything I explained can be
generalized to an arbitrary number of
committers and in particular when this
encryption is under like a set of n
public keys at once rather than just you
okay so the first step and I'll describe
later how to do this but the first step
is to convert these multi key cipher
texts since in nested cipher texts right
so now we have an encryption under
public key one of an encryption under
public key to of the walk value and you
can maybe see it already why this is
useful now under the hood of like take
the second encryption under the hood of
public key one you actually have
something that is a this functions is a
useful input to say the second compete
and compare off these Gatien okay so
we're going to evaluate the compete and
compare these creation ho morphic li
under this public key one okay so we'll
take this guy evaluate the compete and
compare office kitchen so so what's
happening here the you evaluate this
competing care verification on on
I'm locked - so that's going to be
successful and output in particular the
secret key - so what you end up with is
an encryption under secret P - of secret
key - under public key one now
you can use this guy like combine it
with this first encryption here right so
you have now under public key one you
have encryption under public key - of
the lock as well as the secret key to so
you can simply decrypt under the hood to
get an encryption of lock one under
public key one and now this can be
directly plugged into this first
computing compare obfuscation to recover
the secret and message in the clear so
now basically um yeah let's pause for a
second
basically this once you uncover like one
secret key you can kind of like kind of
Rickerson like basically recover every
Oh everything and also note that this
procedure can be also recursed as long
as like if you have an encryption under
like PK one through p KN and you have
like n different computer compare all
these equations you can kind of like
recursively do this two-step procedure
and like basically peel off one one
public key at a time and eventually
recover all the secrets okay one
question is that for the case of many
parties wouldn't the size of these
nested ciphertext guru so yeah they
don't actually grow because each time
like basically in each each time you
peel a layer off you evaluate the
compute and compare off the escape and
then you use that to decrypt and then
you basically update all of the all of
the encryptions and by like basically
peeling off one of the public key layers
so I guess you can see it as like
basically in doing this nested
conversion maybe you're kind of adding a
layer but then you're like peeling it
off with this computing prepare end and
decryption so you're never you never
have to actually blow up the ciphertext
yeah okay right so now it remains to
show basically how to do this conversion
into and did nested ciphertexts so this
is what what it remains to show and to
do this we basically use a special case
of multi key fhe and that is going to be
something referred to as additive
function sharing spooky encryption you
to notice at all and what this is is
this encryption what it allows you to do
is is take to encryption under
independently drawn public keys evaluate
a circuit on them and what you get is
still to encryptions under independently
generated public keys but where the XOR
of the plaintext is actually equal to
the value of the function and this can
be seen as a special case of multi key
fhe where cipher texts have the fault
this particular property like this
particular structure you know an
encryption of X is actually two
encryptions one of Z 1 and 1 is e 2
where Z 1 and Z 2 XOR 10 X so if you
have an encryption in this form then you
convert to a double cipher text as
follows now now you start with your you
do everything kind of ho morphic li
under P k1 so you start with Z 1 and
kind of what you're going to do is
homomorphic Li under P k1 you're going
to homomorphic Li XOR z1 into z2
homomorphic Li under PK 2
ok so this is kind of annoying to look
at but what's going on is you're running
this whole morphic evaluation under PK 2
under PK 1 and what you end up with is
exactly this this nested ciphertext
basically doing you know once you XOR z1
into z2 then you get an encryption of X
under PK 2 so and again this is you know
this generalizes to the multi-party case
okay so this is kind of you know that
the techniques that were needed to
extend kind of this core extraction idea
to to the multi-party setting so with
that I can kind of I can conclude this
part so recall that you know in the end
we actually wanted to be evaluating
these these adversaries when they were
quantum circuits right and when they
didn't when in particular their state is
a quantum state mm-hmm
so basically using the techniques I just
showed like you know if we're given a
quantum multi key fhe scheme where first
we need classical encryptions of
classical messages and this is we need
this because honest parties are
classical and we also needed this
special cypher text structure so we show
we know we extended this this trapdoor
this homomorphic trapdoor paired down to
a naval extraction from multiple
parallel columns of committers and so
you know that's like the basic technique
but then you know we actually have to
build useful cryptographic primitives
out of that and you know in the paper we
show how to use this this technique
combined it yeah
with various other techniques from the
literature basically to to end up with
constant round parallel multi commits
Eric structural commitments as well as
constant round multi verifier zero
knowledge and both of these protocols
are in turn used as building blocks in
our clinic flipping protocol okay so
that just unless there's a questions I
can move on to the next part which will
discuss multi tfhe good okay so now yeah
so we needed quantum multi kfh II and so
I'll you know I'll discuss basically how
we how we get it and so first I'll give
some basically history about about
quantum fhe so these original works
these two works basically they gave a
single key fhg scheme
for evaluating quantum circuits but
where even if you wanted to encrypt a
classical message you you're required to
be quantum and I think and I think
they're also worried about they only
support a bounded evaluation I note that
in our setting it's crucial for for
classical messages to be encrypted by
classical machines and we also need
unbounded evaluation because in general
the our adversaries could be arbitrary
size polynomial circuits arbitrary
polynomial sized circuits and so so Goya
also he gave a a multi key scheme but
also with with the same drawbacks of
quantum encryption and bounded
evaluation so you know finally mahadev
followed by brickowski that they both
gave single key fhe schemes that kind of
satisfy everything we need but in the
single key setting which is you know
unbounded evaluation and classical
encryption property so our approach is
to start with mahadev scheme and extend
it to the multi key setting so now all
of the all of the schemes that I cited
on the last the last slide they all
followed this the same paradigm called
the key encapsulation paradigm and this
makes this makes use of the quantum
one-time pad and so what is this thing
you can take an arbitrary quantum state
you can just use you can draw a
classical bit string so let's say K is
some random classical bits and you can
use those classical bits to perfectly
encrypt this quantum state so it's just
analogous to the the classical one-time
pad so this is basically a perfect
encryption of this de Phi and you can do
this with only classical information so
now a quantum fully homomorphic
encryption and all of these schemes of a
state Phi consists of two parts you you
use a classical fhe scheme to encrypt
the key to a quantum one-time pad and
you give that out along with the the
perfectly mixed state with respect to
the key K
so this is what this is what a qfh a
ciphertext look look looks like so now
how do you do a valuation I I mean I'm
gonna be extremely high level and kind
of not get into any quantum details but
basically for a certain set of quantum
gates which are called Clifford gates
they allow the following very very nice
evaluation procedure so you know take
your take your ciphertext which consists
of two parts you can directly apply the
gate to the quantum part and you arrive
at the updated State v prime but you
know potentially encrypted under a
different key K Prime now completely in
parallel you can run the fhe evaluation
of some circuit that depends on the gate
and update the the key from K to K Prime
and so this final ciphertext will be a
valid encryption of v prime okay so so
this just works for these clifford gates
but the problem is you know clifford
gates are not universal for quantum
computation so you're going to need to
support some non clifford gate and this
is basically where all these schemes on
the last slide different and how they
handle this and so mahadev gave a way to
to evaluate some particular non clifford
gate using you know parallel operations
but also using something called an
encrypted c not where again i won't get
into the details about how it works I
will just show a basically a flowchart
of one one particular step this is
basically the only step that that
requires like this non parallel
evaluation and so this is how it works
or not really how it works but how it
how it looks so you have an encryption
of a bit B which is like say one of the
bits of your key so first you know what
she did is she converted this encryption
into an alternate encryption scheme and
she knew this encryption scheme to
support some special properties that in
general aren't supported by fhe schemes
okay
and then she used you know an encryption
the special form can actually be used to
come up with some some quantum circuit
that evaluates this transformation okay
kind of like kind of uses kind of in
some sense it's actually like
teleporting the bit B into this
superposition and in doing this a
byproduct of this evaluation is a
measurement and what that measurement is
is actually another AAC encryption of
some other bit B Prime and I'm writing
explicitly here the randomness that was
used to generate this encryption so you
actually in doing this transformation
you measure a ciphertext and then as a
final step you actually have to convert
this ciphertext back into an fhe
encryption but not only do you have to
you know transform like convert the the
bit B Prime you also have to uncover an
encryption of the randomness used in
this encryption scheme so this basically
requires a trapdoor for a G basically
some something that allows you to
recover the randomness used to generate
any given ciphertext and you know
basically basically the reason for this
is that the randomness that was used to
generate the cipher text is now somehow
embedded in this key K Prime so of
course you need to like recover an
encryption of this to maintain this
maintain this invariant okay so you know
this is a very high level and I'll go
you know a little bit more into like how
she actually set up these encryption
schemes so what was used was for fhe was
a dual version of the g SW fully
homomorphic encryption scheme and for
ahe it turns out that the the basic dual
reg of scheme actually satisfies the
property is necessary to carry out this
this operation here
you know FHN fhe scheme doesn't satisfy
the properties but it turns out the dual
reeow does and so this is actually
particularly nice for the following
reason so let's look at what a dual GSW
encryption of a bit b would be so you
have a you have a public matrix a
you know a s + e and then you basically
add bit B times the gadget matrix this
is just what dual GSW looks like now now
note that the fun if you just take the
final column of this ciphertext this is
exactly a dual rag of encryption of B
okay
that's just what it is so this means
that if a if this fhe public key is
drawn along of the trapdoor tau then
that trapped errata matically also
functions as a trapdoor for the dual
read of scheme okay because it's a
trapdoor for a so therefore like if you
just draw this fhe public key of the
trapdoor you can then use that trapdoor
in this conversion and so and so you're
done so good so you know our our
challenge now is to basically what we
want to do is we want to replace the
single key classical fhe
in this in this scheme with a with a
multi key classical fhe hopefully in
order to derive like a quantum multi key
fhe okay so remember that the the single
key fhe that was used was a dual GSW
with the trapdoor so we're asking the
question does there exist a multi key
fhj scheme where even like multi key
cipher texts come along with the
trapdoor okay so you know there's
various multi classical multi fhe
schemes in the literature and so they
pretty much all have to support a
procedure of the following form it's
called expand so here you you have an
encryption of a bit be under some under
some public key PKA and you also have a
bunch of independently generated public
keys if you k1c began and you want to
somehow run a procedure that converts
this encryption into an encryption of a
bit under all the public keys at once
okay
so this is a you need to you somehow
need to support this this key expansion
procedure now what we're wondering then
is okay say that each of these public
keys is drawn along with the trapdoor is
there an analogous trapdoor
expansion procedure that like given the
description of these trapdoors produces
a trapdoor that functions as a trapdoor
for this expanded ciphertext okay so
this is what we're wondering that does
there exist such a thing and it actually
turns you know it's not it's certainly
not immediate and it's uh seems a little
difficult to come up with such a thing
because well for run reason is you know
in GSW and dual GSW the ciphertext
always maintains the following nice form
like something like a s plus e now in
all of these works the expanded cipher
texts are you know highly structured but
in a very different way and in
particular they they lose this form and
and they don't really have a nice
structure and it's unclear how to
combine trapdoors for each of the
individual a matrices to obtain a
trapdoor for this for the six-man that
second counts
so so what we do instead okay
is we basically note that in all of
these in all of these schemes expanded
cipher texts do satisfy the following
property and that property is nearly
linear decryption okay so given any
cipher texts you can compute a publicly
you can probably compute a linear
function based on that ciphertext such
that if you take the inner product of
you know this vector with the
concatenated set of secret keys then you
get then you basically uncover the bit
be masked by or with just added with
just a little bit of of noise so
decryption is just you know evaluate a
linear function and then round and then
maybe divided by Q over two so we're
basically just going to take advantage
of the fact that this that these multi
fhe ciphertext support of such a simple
decryption procedure clear which is you
know been taken advantage of in many
other works but so so what we're going
to do is you know even though our m fhe
ciphertext even though this may not have
a trapdoor what we're going to do is
switch into a scheme where multi key
ciphertex do have a trapdoor and so key
switching is basically just you know
just bootstrapping but going from one
scheme to another scheme so you know
homomorphic so what we can do is
homomorphic lee under this alternate
scheme which i haven't described yet MLH
e we can homework home Orphic we run the
decryption circuit of M fhe right and
the key is that because this decryption
circuit is pretty much just a linear
function
you know things work out such that this
MLH a scheme only has to support linear
homomorphism okay and because of that we
can actually define an easy trapdoor
expansion procedure for this ml edgy
scheme so in particular if each of these
public keys is drawn along with the
trapdoor then the expanded ciphertext
actually just has as its trapdoor
concatenation of all the trapdoors so
basically you know on the next slide
we'll see a little bit like more clearly
like how this is like why this works but
essentially that the point is that we
just took advantage of the fact that the
MM fhe has linear decryption to first
convert this ciphertext into like a
scheme that only needs to support a
limited class of homomorphism okay in
order to define this trapdoor expansion
so finally I can basically I can
basically describe like some simplified
version of the final quantum multi key
fhat gen which you know starts by by
running the keygen of of some classical
multi key fhe scheme and now what you
want to do is encrypt this secret key
right under under the ML HG scheme and
so the MLA cheese lhe scheme we use is
basically just going to be a natural
extension of dual records okay so to
compute this encryption we're just
basically going to compute a dual reg of
encryption of SK 1 and to do that we'll
generate a public matrix along with the
trapdoor
well encrypt this this is just a
standard dual reg of encryption that
supports linear home or ism
that's why these this power of two this
year and so basically then yeah so that
this d1 is the the ciphertext and then
you can output the public key which
consists of this public key along with
an encryption of the secret key so let's
say like another guy comes along and
does the same thing and dependently our
goal is to then you know during a multi
key ihe evaluation at some point we'll
come across a multi key fh easkey
encryption of the bit B under two public
keys and you know while this may not
have a trapdoor what we want to do is
convert it into an MLG ciphertext that
indeed does have the trapdoor and we
want that trapdoor to just consists of
tau 1 and tau 2 so we'll just do this
with linear home morphism so first you
know compute the appropriate linear
function based on the ciphertext we have
to dip bit decomposed it just just just
to support linear homomorphism and then
usually what you would do if you want is
if you want to compute this linear
function over these two secret keys you
would just take the two ciphertext and
like compute these these products and
then add them up so on our setting you
know d1 and d2 are encrypted under
different public keys so instead will
kind of be this staggered thing and if
you like basically work out what this is
is you end up with an encryption of the
bit B under this ciphertext which looks
exactly like a dual reg of cipher text
except that it's it's public he has this
basically this block diagonal structure
and because of that so this is what
we're calling our ml HG ciphertext and
because of that like you know you can
use this trapdoor tau1 to recover all of
the the secrets in the top half here and
you can use the chapter two to recover
all the secrets in the bottom half and
so this this is why this this thing
functions is a trapdoor for this
ciphertext and then and you know this is
already in like dual reggae form so it
can be used directly in the encrypted c
not operation okay and so you know again
they're the reason that we're able to do
this is you know the reason that this is
such a simple trapdoor expand
in here is because this only needed to
support linear homomorphism so it can
basically just line up the public keys
in an in block diagonal form so okay so
that's basically just the main idea and
so what we get is you know the final
result of this section basically is if
you have any classical and multi kfh a
scheme that supports nearly linear
decryption you can compile it into a
quantum multi key fa g screen and you
know something that I didn't mention is
you know most classical multi khe
schemes in the literature require c RS
but you know we don't have access to
that in our setting so instead we use
the bhp fhe scheme that supports
distributed set up and so it has an
alien a decryption so it can just be
plugged into our compiler and finally
again we needed a special cipher text
structure but this is basically
straightforward to achieve with another
application of key switching and then
using like the techniques and Ottis at
all you know the main tip the main
conclusion here is like it's
straightforward like if you have a
classical multi kfh scheme with this
nearly linear decryption property then
you can and then you can just get right
away a comb to multi kfh a scheme so
yeah that's going to be so I have one
more part so if there's any questions
maybe now would be a good time yeah so
so finally I will discuss non-viable
commitments right so so let's go back at
this point to our to our template for
coin flipping and let's instantiate it
with like the primitives that we've
constructed so now each party is going
samples random string and use a parallel
extractable commitment to to commit to
it and then broadcast it and then
everyone's going to prove in parallel
zero knowledge that you know they were
consistent and their commitment so
there's one issue to resolve here and
this is a malleability issue it still
comes up so consider an adversary that's
that's corrupting some some party Pete
you say in this first stage you know
that there's an honest party p1 that's
that's committing to its string r1
committing to the adversary right while
at the same time the adversary is
broadcasting its own commitment to its
own random string so it turns out that
you know what if the adversary could
somehow make its commitment to are to
depend on the commitment to r1 being
sent by p1 and this is you know the fact
that a the possibility that an adversary
could do that is actually not ruled out
by the hiding of this commitment scheme
so and of course if adversary can do
that then I can bias the final outcome R
okay so we basically need to solve this
issue and this is solved by using a
non-viable commitment and so so what is
the definition of such a thing basically
consider any two two different messages
consider this experiment okay so now
adversaries in this in this world are
called man-in-the-middle so this is mi m
and so this man in the middle is
interacting with an honest party
committing to the message m1 on the left
and at the same time it's broadcasting
its own commitment and this experiment
is going to fix the following
distribution which is the final state of
the adversary as well as the commitment
that are broadcasted on the right okay
and then we can consider the analogous
experiment in the case that it's being
in the case of m2 is being committed on
the left and we want to say that these
these distributions are
indistinguishable and this this
intuitively gives non malleability right
because you know that implies that you
know if m star is distributed like
indistinguishably and go
of these experiments that means it
couldn't have like depended in any like
non-trivial way on which of these
messages was sent on the left okay so
this is like the kind of security we
want to achieve but how would you how
would you prove such a thing if you you
know if you think about it intuitively
what a reduction will have to do at some
point is to interact with the man in the
middle that's the reduction is going to
sign at some point have to like previous
these this distribution and so in order
to do that it's going to sound it's
going to need to extract from the man in
the middle like what value of committed
on the right well at the same time you
know not breaking the hiding of the
committee on the left because you know
realistically like that's the that this
hiding is gonna be based on some hard
computational assumption that the
reduction will be reducing to so that's
the that's kind of the paradigm and on
my little commitments is like how do you
extract on the right while maintaining
hiding on the left so so many works on
non-viable commitments basically just
take this tag based approach where each
commitment comes along with with an
identity or a tag of the person that
committed okay so in MPC setting every
party is just going to have their own
their own tag and now the guarantee is
that like this non my ability only holds
if the man in the Middle's tag so tag
prime is is different than the honesty
motives tag on the left now in order to
like build these things many works just
take a two-step approach so first you
show how to construct a non mile
commitment that supports a very small
tags based for example like a
logarithmic or even loss mm-hmm
and then you show some some sort of tag
amplification theorem so this I will not
touch on at all because you know this
and the paper we show such a thing in
the post quantum setting but it just
follows standard techniques so for this
first one what you could do okay so
first I will say that you know as far as
we're aware there hadn't been any any
prior works that explicitly studied like
you know post quantum nah my will
commitments in the plane model which is
what we want so we could just take
although we what we do note is that like
we could instantiate the approach of
pass and we based on complexity
leveraging and in a straightforward
pretty straightforward way achieve post
quantum non-viable commitments under
sub-exponential assumptions okay but we
kind of took this as a opportunity to
really you know initiate the study of
post quantum non-viable commitments as
well and so we want to try to reduce the
Assumption strength of the assumption as
much as possible so rather than doing
that we'll follow a slightly more
sophisticated approach that will give
eventually a better assumption and so
this is the approach of Corona and Sahai
from 2017 okay so a few remarks about
that so what this approach is is it okay
for a small tax base what a commitment
is it's going to be a mechanism that
actually transmits so it's supposed to
be hiding right but it will actually
transmit the message to the receiver
with some small probability so a small
probability I mean that since it is
hiding this this ADA has to be some some
super polynomial function of lambda and
in fact this probability is going to
kind of be inversely proportional to the
actual actual tag which we're saying is
some integer between 1 and then okay so
we want to also set this up in a way
where the committer actually can't tell
whether the message was transmitted to
the receiver or not and so this this is
you know you can V this as some kind of
an eraser channel and you can set this
up using basically statistically send a
private to BC or a week version of it
that only needs to support
indistinguishability based security and
you know you can you can set this up in
a post quantum way using statistically a
sender private OT from LW which was
built by brick Erskine darling and this
technique of instantiating the ratio
channel with ot from LW was also used in
KS in the setting of witness
indistinguishability so you know once
you have this eraser channel you can sit
you can consider the following you know
if the man in the middle has a tag is
tagged with something that's smaller
than the tag of the comater on the left
then this intuitively it enables this
sort of extraction on the right while
hiding on the left because if this tag
prime is smaller then it's you know it's
easier to learn the message on the right
than it is on the left just because of
how we set up these these transmission
probabilities so that's good so what
about the other case so this is more
problematic but you know what these you
know what these works do is basically
set up to erase your channels executed
sequentially so one is going to transmit
you know with you know one over like a
tit to the tag the other one is going to
be one over a to the N minus static so
those so these are executed sequentially
and there's always going to be one of
the two that enables extraction on the
right while hiding on the left and
basically you could [ __ ] like in the
proof if you have to use the fact that
basically these are like extraction in
these two eraser channels is happening
with independent like there are
independent events and you can like
basically take advantage of that to to
eventually approve security so you know
this is all this is similar to the
approach taken in Corona and Soho and I
just wanted to basically finish by just
saying a few words about like the
differences between our work in their
work so they show a a reduction so their
reduction is like is rewinding the men
in the middle basically until the
commitment on the right is extracted
okay
so this is no good in the post quantum
setting so instead we use a non
rewinding proof technique that instead
of like relying on you know extraction
we basically can only argue about a
differences in success probabilities to
get the reduction to go through okay so
the the other thing is that because they
wanted to because their goal was
reducing round complexity as much as
possible they wanted like a two round
non-viable commitment and for that they
actually needed a complexity leveraging
and which eventually results were in
sub-exponential assumptions so on the
other hand were able to leverage in a
different way and particularly leverage
a statistical security parameter and
this gives us the ability to only rely
on this like very mildly superpolynomial
assumption that i that i stated at the
beginning of the talk which was
basically one over like lambda to the
iterated log of lambda but you know it's
an it's it's very close to polynomial
but i you know it's an interesting
problem it leaves at least open an
interesting problem before that you can
get you know post quantum not liable
commitments from truly polynomial
assumptions okay now so I'm almost done
I mean so now once once we have the this
non-viable commitment we can like kind
of plug it into the beginning of our
coin flipping protocol and it eventually
kind of looks like this where each party
commits to their string as well as the
randomness at first and then they and
then they send an extractor commitment
to their string using this this
randomness and so this this s comes up
in the security proof that's basically
another way to tie the to tie the non
malleability of this commitment to the
extraction of this commitment and you
know eventually eventually we give like
basically a proof for this whole thing
that you know doesn't rely on on any
rewinding and is you know it truly votes
quantum and so basically for details
about like I won't be able to get into
like details about like the proof
subtleties or techniques or anything but
for that doll energy to see the paper
so yeah so with that I can I can
conclude basically we have maybe three
contributions I mean so one is one is a
way to extend this this recently
introduced like seemingly very powerful
no-cloning non rewinding simulation
technique to the parallel or to the
multi-party setting okay so we show how
to do this and you know as we saw like
extending it to this multi-party setting
has already had applications as we saw
in our paper but could reasonably have
others we also give the first multi
quantum multi tfhe with classical
encryption of classical messages which
again may have other applications and
finally we initiate the study of post
quantum non liable commitments okay and
then this all is combined to get to our
main results of constant around
classical npc say here against quantum
adversaries and so in terms of
applications there there was this paper
from last year that gave they actually
constructed a quantum NPC a protocol for
for competing any arbitrary quantum
circuit but the head just assumed the
existence of post quantum and classical
NPC so I'm particular our protocol could
be plugged into theirs and we think you
know maybe there should be more
applications but we leave that to future
work and so that's it thanks for
listening ok great let me stop the
recording